this video is brought to you by
manscape.com dragon ball super has been
finished or more optimistically on
hiatus for well over three years or 1
285 days but who's counting hunter
hunter eat your heart out in the last 1
285 days the dragon ball super manga has
introduced us to a host of new
characters that have never been animated
let alone seen an adaptation into the
current anime style and so while i can't
animate an entire series in a week i do
have a talented team of artists and i am
all out of patience so without further
ado let's transform the likes of maris
morrow and granola into what they will
eventually look like once the anime
comes out
whoa whoa whoa
while we will be taking characters from
the super manga to adapt into an anime
style unlike the last two videos we
won't be converting them into the dragon
ball z style but instead more fittingly
into the style of naohiro shintani the
character designer of dragon ball super
broly we want to get as close as humanly
possible to what these characters will
look like in the show once it does
eventually come back and so this seems
like the safest bet that means manga
centric pastel colors rounder shapes and
bolder line work in short i'm very
excited to see how this one turns out
and the first one up to draw is
me
taken out of the closing moments of
goku's fight with moro in chapter 64
this is the proof of concept piece we
put together last week when figuring out
whether this was a viable video the
thing is trying to nail down exactly
what nawahiro shintani's style looks
like is surprisingly difficult shintani
auditioned for the role of character
designer and it was akira toriyama who
picked him based on his exceptional
skills with anatomy according to
toriyama as long as you pick a good
artist first their understanding of
dragon ball style will naturally develop
over time and he was 100 right the
illustration of goku with nyobo was
shintani's audition piece and although
great it had some scrunched facial
features but by the time he finished his
designs for the broly movie those issues
had been ironed out entirely and looking
further to recent pieces he's only
developed an even greater understanding
however while his improvements have been
incredible to watch develop this
shifting style has made it hard to nail
down exactly what his approach looks
like luckily for us however we have a
recent anniversary short along with his
recent magazine illustrations which
showcase a number of consistent aspects
to draw from with this ultra instinct
test piece however i took a look at the
way shintani had drawn the muscles on
characters like broly paying careful
attention to the mix of curves and
angles and how he makes sure not to
segment the muscles too much instead
falling back on shading to add volume
all i needed then was a quick glance at
the super saiyan god drawing for the
hair and it was all good to go all
that's left is to add the finishing
touches and
once i saw this i knew i had to make a
video on it not just because i thought
it was interesting but because i had to
know what the likes of mora would look
like in the series when it returns
speaking of which next up
trend taken out of chapter 51 wherein
moro regains his youth comes the first
real look we get at the newly
rejuvenated warlock as far as designs go
i appreciated this version of him much
more than his later incarnations where
he became a bit of a cell knockoff it is
however for that very reason this
character and his design was difficult
to adapt whether or not you like this
design it is unique to dragon ball so we
didn't find there was much room for
innovation in the face instead trev
focused on rounding up the muscles and
shading in a way reminiscent of shintani
most importantly though something you
may be asking yourself at this point is
what in the hell is with that tiny alias
brush you're using it's doing nothing to
help the drawing here well one thing i
wasn't prepared for in this video was
how different the process would be in
replicating dragon ball super broly's
composite or filter if you prefer in our
dbz fine videos all we had to do was
line our pieces as normal using a
textured brush before aj would throw his
filter down to bring the piece to life
that same approach would not work for us
here and so we needed an expert enter
mix we brought this fellow on board
because he figured out a way of
replicating the lineart and lighting
effects seen in dragon ball super broly
and now even one piece is wanna arc
although this is something tatsuya
nagamine the director of broly and wano
developed and not shintani it's a look
that stuck around and we felt it was
best to keep it going as it's so
strongly associated with the new dragon
ball content now in modern anime
although almost everything is still hand
drawn on paper it gets scanned in and
converted into fairly thin alias single
color line this is partly to allow
colorists to achieve edge-to-edge
coloring as smooth anti-alias brushes
have many different tones that make it
impossible to get a perfect fill but
it's also to allow the compositing team
to treat the lines as they see fit
sometimes that's through basic
anti-aliasing to smooth them out again
but other times they're treated with
stylistic effects in our case we have
this inky brush look the line art may
look very amateur to start with but once
we apply mix's filter
thanks to him we added some much needed
line weight and some diffused lining
effects too that's oversimplified a bit
but it really does elevate the piece
it's very authentic great job trev and
great job mix
next up
trev again
if you've taken a cursory glance at the
internet and seen a lot of fan attempts
at no hiroshintani style you may have
felt they looked too round or lacked a
serious edge the scenes needed
unfortunately that's because a lot of
people very much misunderstand his
design philosophy and draw from the
wrong line of thinking shintani's
designs are all about versatility in an
interview leading up to broly shintani
spoke in depth about his approach and he
said the everyday life scenes don't have
very much shading but when the movie
ramps up into battle mode the shading
increases and the muscles pop out more
clearly providing greater contrast that
makes for a cool impression using the
same shading throughout would weaken the
impact of the parts we want to show off
most so we wanted the visuals themselves
to clearly say it's time for battle in
summary soft with minimal shading for
lighthearted scenes and more angular and
shaded for action and so trev here had
one hell of a job as shintani's serious
work is wildly different from toyotaros
here he produced strong voluptuous
muscle shapes with isolated bubble
shading that added a great deal of depth
along with a fairly old-school face
similar to the styles seen in some of
recent shintani illustrations all that's
left is from mix to composited nicely
and
that's one sexy ass alter-ego vegeta
next up on the opposite end of the
spectrum it's aj in spite of all the
action in chapter 76 the very same
chapter the previous vegeta came from
there's a moment of brevity in the form
of a flashback that unveils granola's
mother hugging her son in relief as he
returns home in the midst of a saiyan
invasion and this one was interesting to
tackle shintani's approach to female
characters is to draw them largely one
to one with modern toriyama's approach
this means fairly lanky limbs large
heads and cute expressions although
toyotaro's drawing is fairly close it
needed some significant rounding off and
proportion adjustment along with a
massive pose overhaul to make what was
originally a very wide panel fit within
a 16x9 space thankfully there are many
references for women in dragon ball
super broly such as guinea chili and
bulma so converting this drawing across
ended up looking pretty convincing large
eyes simplified hair cute blobby limbs
it's all in place and its approach to
shading stands in direct contrast to the
previous vegeta as this is a touching
scene reuniting a mother and son throw
in a background some speed lines and
granola's mother is brought to life it's
clean and it's smooth but you know what
else is clean and smooth
manscape.com if you've been subscribed
for a while you'll know i keep my balls
in great shape thanks to my previous
manscape partnership to keep my manly
jojo body in check for the sake of ease
i'm sure most of us would like to do our
grooming in the shower and so thankfully
the lawnmower 4.0 makes that possible
thanks to its 100 cordless and
waterproof design no cuts smooth
trimming adjustable guards i have total
confidence here and it is totally
pain-free one of the coolest new
features however is the wireless
charging system doubling is a handy
stand for the mower this thing charges
fast and is great for up to 90 minutes
on a full battery it really is the full
package for my package after you get
yourself all trim and proper it's
important to keep your skin feeling
great with manscape's crop preserver
ball deodorant just a dollop of this
quick absorbing clear drying lotion will
keep you protected all day it's as
simple as that with a nose and ear
trimmer in their new weed whacker it
really is the perfect all-in-one
grooming kit so if you're looking to
find the right tools for your family
jewels head over to manscape.com and use
promo code not mark 20 for 20 off plus
free international shipping your balls
will thank you
[Music]
up to draw
trev as far as characters go maris was
one of the best additions to the moral
arc i think he injected a pretty
interesting question by shining a much
more nuanced light on the story the
whole with great power comes great
responsibility argument i could see was
echoing in his head and yet he was
forced to holster that power for what he
was told was for the betterment of the
universe i'm a big fan of this character
and with this particular piece of
artwork we had to adjust the original
pain's composition typically when
adapting manga to an anime format as you
saw in the last piece you have to make
alterations for it to fit within a 16x9
aspect ratio this all comes down to
framing and compositional awareness the
first goku piece at the beginning of the
video was initially a test to see if
this would actually work as a concept
for a video so little thought was put
into changing it up for tv in this
particular case we altered the original
by playing around with the position of
the incoming fist and added smears and
speed effect lines for the punch to
better match how it would look in
animation the result looks promising but
in reality we won't know how good it
looks until we apply mix's filter
and there we have it as authentic as
ever let this serve as perhaps an
indication of how this character might
be depicted once it makes it to our
screens one day in the future next up
yours truly
the beauty of converting styles for the
purposes of a video like this is that we
get to effectively work as animation
supervisors the staff members on an
episode in charge of ensuring drawings
are anatomically sound and on model in
the same way they do we're often drawing
over someone else's artwork keeping what
works and changing other aspects and
shapes contained within the drawing to
bring it more in line with what we
expect from the shintani design sheets
honestly as artists it feels a bit weird
with our views on tracing but this is
how it's done in the industry so we're
following suit in other words if we're
lucky in the bass drawing is solid we
can just change the shapes and feature
placement a little and call it a day but
in some instances we run into minor
anatomical issues that require our
addressing and this is often part of the
adaptation process and so due to this
reality when it came to converting this
piece into shintani's style i not only
had to change the style itself but i
ended up having to redraw the
foundational drawing of that one arm and
that was just the first struggle many of
these new characters only have their
official colors revealed via the full
color manga which uses very saturated
colors that just don't look anything
like the color design seen in modern
dragon ball content and so our solution
was this use the manga colors as a
reference and then find and adjust
existing colors in broly to match them
best unfortunately for me i referenced
this image for how to color him and that
image happens to be one of the only
instances where 73 is colored
incorrectly there's actually a mistake
on his chest thankfully though this
mistake was caught before we finalized
the images just gotta throw it through
the filter now and
there you have it the arm is fixed the
style is shifted and the color is
accurate very happy with the way this
one turned out
next up
editor-san the female trio from the
galactic bandit brigade don't play a
major part in the morrow arc but their
battle against rosh is a fun one and
tackling more aggressive looking girls
with a shintani twist seem like an
interesting idea so here we are editor
stan sure had his work cut out for him
with this one not only did he have three
characters to rework but their fairly
detailed designs and trying to refine
them into something suitable for
animation is no easy feat following the
aforementioned philosophy of less is
more he cut back on the excessive lines
in the hair and let the shading do the
talking not too much however for a
couple of reasons the first is that this
is largely a comedic fight centered
around roshi's pervy antics but secondly
because even in serious situations
characters like chile never ended up
with quite as much of an extreme shading
increase so it was important to reflect
that reality here something he also
noticed immediately was that the center
girl was well she was missing a neck in
the original panel toyotaro was clearly
after an aggressive hunch shoulders look
but didn't quite nail it additionally to
better frame the panel in 16x9 editor
sand twisted her torso around allowing
for a more dynamic and balanced pose
with the rest of the team and most
importantly he restored the poor girl's
neck personally i think the best
addition he made was in varying up the
facial expressions to give each
individual character their own
distinctive personality admittedly it's
a slightly liberal take but one that i
think looks convincing and fitting and
with a little tlc from trev on the
eyebrows and shading it's ready for mix
to step in
beautifully blended in with those
distinctive inky lines and lovely
ambient lighting and you'd be forgiven
for thinking that this was right out of
an existing episode
nice job everyone and next up me
in reality shintani's design philosophy
is quite different from toyotaro's and
it has to be animation and illustration
are two very different mediums manga is
made up of stills so you can be as
detailed as you'd like but animation has
thousands of different drawings per
episode and they all need to be
consistent from one to another therein
lies the real challenge when adapting
from manga to anime designs one of the
major major shortcomings of yamamuro's
designs for super was how difficult they
were to animate rigid shapes with a
large number of lines do not make for a
forgiving design while super's crumbling
schedule brought about most of its
animation issues the designs for the
series certainly didn't do it any favors
this is the exact opposite of what
shintani's designs offered when he
overhauled the designs for the series
going into broly and so i had to keep
that in mind for my piece gas and alex
faces were pretty straightforward all i
had to do for ellick was to reference
goku's character sheets to form an
approximation of his face while gas on
the other hand was a little more
difficult fortunately though for me he
resembles kid buu and he pops up for
about a split second in the broly movie
giving me an easy reference okay two
faces done the clothes and hair however
were a whole other story in the manga
they're filled with complex lines that
just wouldn't work from an animation
standpoint but also turn into an
unreadable mess once mix's line filter
was applied in response to this i
reduced the number of lines and fell
back on simple shading instead to add
detail and depth and i think it worked
out pretty well to bring it all together
i grabbed the colors from whis's broly
movie character design and there you
have it all we gotta do now is apply the
filter and
those are some blue boys and might i add
that i love the crazy flare effects used
in this instance too if you're familiar
with magumi ishitani's work on dragon
ball super in one piece you'll know she
loves a good lens flare move out of the
way jj abrams very cinematic and
convincing but next up is me again
looking on as his surrogate's son makes
perhaps the biggest mistake of his life
comes this panel of mineto truth be told
i don't draw namekians very much and
i've never drawn an old one as far as i
can remember and so going into this
coupled with a strange angle and billowy
cloak i was certain this would be a
nightmare to fully realize but in
reality it ended up being the easiest of
my drawing surprisingly monito is
originally a toriyama design and seeing
as shintani didn't seem to do a whole
lot to change toriyama's stuff in broly
i tried to create a hybrid of toyotaro's
final version and toriyama's initial
version for the character both toyotaro
and toriyama have pretty different
approaches so this meant i needed my
interpretation to be more of a hybrid
meaning more regular proportions like
toyotaro but with rounder shapes like
toriyama the only real challenge i came
across was in finding an official color
palette for monito as a character and as
of writing this video the color manga
still hasn't arrived at his introduction
to the series yet however aj did manage
to find me the perfect and perhaps only
colored image of this character by
toyotaro at this point outside of that
everything was just cleaning up on the
details big blobby shapes on the cloak
for shading and now it's time for mix's
filter
i'm very happy with how this one turned
out very convincing and now moving on to
my last drawing next up is me of all the
pieces i've worked on in this video this
drawing here was the biggest struggle
not just because of the compositing
issues it later presented us with but
also because of the anatomical
abnormalities it continued to yield the
more i worked on it as i touched on
before during my drawing of 7-3
corrections to certain poses and manga
panels are a pretty standard affair when
adapting for the screen while i
absolutely see what toyotara was going
for in this piece when i started to lay
down the underlying anatomy to work on
this style shift i realized that not
only was the neck in the wrong place but
so too was the foremost arm itself and
when the shoulders arms and head are the
most important aspects of this piece
there ended up being very little i could
keep outside of the back and opposing
arm but in the end with a lot of trial
and error i managed to finish on
something i wasn't too unhappy with
facially it took a while to get things
right but thanks to the numerous
shintani illustrations out there i think
i managed to land on something pretty
convincing compositing was a big concern
with this one however auras and dragon
ball go pretty much hand in hand but in
super they became so blown out that it
honestly made it difficult to see the
underlying artwork while these
computer-generated auras were present in
broly also they were by design
significantly more readable particularly
when compared with super's counterparts
and so finding the effects and proper
balance to yield an authentic result was
quite tough but in the end once we
applied the final filter the results i
think speak for themselves this was a
struggle but it was worth it
next up with the final drawing of this
video
is trev
i absolutely adore granola's character
design in the manga there's a sort of
western gunslinger vibe he comes
packaged with and we wanted to preserve
that aspect of this persona here when we
selected this shot to create our own
approximation for an anime counterpart
with this one the biggest issues we face
came from our struggle to source an
appropriate backdrop to this one time
panel in the end we settled on this
hallway shot from frieza's ship in broly
trev also approached a large variety of
different shading styles and angles to
find what best suited partially drawing
from takahashi's section in the broly
movie in the end we went with something
quite striking and dramatic considering
the light is emanating from his
fingertips now something that did get a
little out of hand while super was on
the air was this notion that highlights
on characters equal bad when it comes to
dragon ball's anime however in reality
that is completely untrue highlights
aren't evil misuse of them is and boy
have they been misused over the years
but in the case of this image here that
trev is working on it makes complete
sense to use them due to it being highly
lit and this isn't a case of us picking
or choosing favorites either by the way
if we wind the clocks back and look at
dragon ball z you'll find them there
where appropriate too and even more
recently within the broly movie in the
end it's all how you choose to apply
them dragon ball super reached a point
where their presence made everyone look
like they were coated in oil with super
dragon ball heroes using it as a means
of showing health basically and in short
if used correctly this can be used to
tremendous effect to heighten the drama
of a particular scene and so while
keeping all of that in mind let's see
how this looks after we apply the filter
here you can see that mix has decided to
add his own changes like adding blur
around the edges to bring his face and
fingertips more into focus and that
coupled with the diffused lighting and
trev's incredible illustrative ability
make for i think magnificently
stupendous results
looking back at this video i was
incredibly blown away by the final
pieces on display i have an amazing team
one that without a video like this would
have been simply impossible to create in
the description as always you'll find a
list of all their social media accounts
and for the purposes of this video
specifically i'd like to shout out
mixtuskela on twitter for his incredible
knowledge and proficiency with that line
filter tool reminiscent of broly's art
design we couldn't have done it without
you fair warning though is twitter's a
little not safe for work so tread
carefully my friends but with that said
i can't wait to see what the future
holds for dragon ball i can't wait to
see if we end up being close with our
approximations of these shots but more
than anything else i hope you enjoyed
the video i'll see you all next week and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
hmm